buongiorno
allora io sono qui per raccontarvi una
storia che avrebbe necessità di un tempo
molto lungo
mi sono fatta una scaletta per riuscire
a condensare tutto quello che è successo
dagli anni 40 in poi in modo che voi
abbiate lo stimolo per andare a
informarvi e sapere quello che è
successo in modo più dettagliato
direi che il discorso inizia nella fine
degli anni quaranta inizio degli anni 50
quando nel mondo si sta lavorando da
fare l'energia atomica e tutte le
università cominciano a pensare di
studiare per fare qualche cosa
tre università italiane milano roma e
pisa decidono di fare il sincrotrone che
è un'apparecchiatura per la fissione
però in quel periodo è nato anche il cnr
e il cnr decide che il singolo né lo
farò ma per cui pisa insieme a luca e
livorno avevano preparato 150 milioni
per questa ricerca si trovano con in
mano
questi soldi se non sapere cosa farne in
quel periodo
enrico fermi era in italia
e allora gli chiedono cosa possono farne
lui ha detto guardate secondo me dovete
cominciare a lavorare sul computer
perché in america ci stanno lavorando e
credo che sia necessario allora
cominciano a lavorare a pisa ma si
accorgono di sen 50 milioni sono molto
pochi
allora scrivono alle aziende italiane
grosse per sentire chi volesse
partecipare a questa avventura
rispondere olivetti perché adriano aveva
già in testa di portare la sua azienda
anche nell'elettronica e cominciano a
collaborare
i primi tre che vengono coinvolti
sono ecco milano compra invece un
computer in america roma lo compra la
ferranti mentre pisa decide di farlo in
modo da poter avere un know how per
tutti i suoi studenti e cominciano a
fare questo computer che poi sarà
realizzato e si chiama il computer
picciano e viene coinvolto dalla
olivetti mario su mario c è il figlio
dell'ambasciatore dell'impero cinese in
vaticano ha fatto tutto il liceo in roma
ha iniziato l'università a roma poi che
su consiglio del padre va in america in
america prima e studente e poi quando
adriano lo va a cercare è libero docente
alla columbia university
sull'elettronica
questo è il gruppo di barbaricina perché
l'olivetti si accorda con lei studioso
di fisica e cominciano a collaborare
dopo un po ci si accorge che io vi
consiglierei poi di andare su internet
oppure compra dei libri per conoscere il
personaggio su perché era il personaggio
che ha introdotto veramente in italia
l'informatica all'elettronica a quei
tempi si parlava di cervelli elettronici
ci davano di gente che faceva la bomba
atomica non era ancora formalizzata
anche a livello di terminologia come
oggi
e ciò è veramente un personaggio
importante avessimo tempo che
racconterei come mi ha assunto che
personaggio era ma non abbiamo il tempo
allora ci si accorge che l'obiettivo
della facoltà di fisica era quello di
fare un computer scientifico mentre lui
aveva bisogno di dare una mano ad
adriano per far sì che venisse accettata
anche in azienda olivetti l'elettronica
voi dovete sapere che a quei tempi
l'olivetti era leader a livello mondiale
nel calcolo meccanico aveva un
personaggio molto importante chi era
cappellaro che ha fatto la division la
tetraktis che sono calcolatrici
meccaniche insuperate a livello mondiale
con dei margini di contribuzione 1 a 10
cosa impensabile oggi e allora ci siamo
staccati dalla facoltà di fisica e siamo
andati in una villa barbaricina
sempre in zona pisa dove abbiamo
cominciato a lavorare per realizzare un
calcolatore commerciale il calcolatore
era la 0 a valvole poi abbiamo fatto la
uno che era ancora valvole ma non più
montata in modo disordinato ma montata
su dei re che con delle piastre
standardizzate end e orfi flop e così
via
e poi ci ha fatto una scelta molto nel
futuro ha scelto di passare dalle
valvole ai transistor a quei tempi il
transito era ancora un oggetto
misterioso era pericoloso usarlo ma con
questa decisione ci è riuscito a
realizzare il primo computer al mondo
commerciale l'elea 9003 a transistor per
cui l'olivetti è in concorrenza con la
siemens che dice che sia stata prima la
siemens però la siemens e il suo aveva
alcune parti ancora valvole delle a 9300
è completamente a francisco
io vi auguro e vi consiglio di andare a
bibbiena dove ne esiste un esemplare
ancora funzionante all'istituto enrico
fermi di bibbiena
dopo questa esperienza fatta a barbare
cina e tutto si è trasferito a borgo
lombardo a sud di milano
lì abbiamo cominciato a produrre in
serie l'elea 9003 e sono stati fatti 44
esemplari il primo andato alla a
valdagno alla marzotto che controllava
la gestione dei magazzini mentre il
secondo è andata al monte dei paschi di
siena che controllava
i conti correnti della banca
quell'esemplare lì nel 1972 è stato
regalato all istituto enrico fermi di
bibbiena per cui li hanno tutto il
calcolatore tutta la documentazione e
hanno veramente tutto quello che si può
vedere di un computer che è stato
presentato nel 1959 a gronchi a milano
qui è lo stabilimento di borgo lombardo
dove si cominciava già a produrre l'elea
9003 questo ettore sottsass un altro
personaggio che molto probabilmente gli
architetti conoscono e l'uomo che ha
rivoluzionato a livello mondiale come si
costruivano computer a quei tempi ha
introdotto una dimensione bassa in modo
che nel centro di calcolo potessero
vedersi gli operatori ha introdotto al
colore ha introdotto la possibilità di
aprirlo al libro è un'altra variante
molto importante che ha fatto è stata
quella di inventare la blindosbarra per
cui non c'era più il pavimento
attrezzato dove passavano i cavi che
quando faceva una modifica una
riparazione
dovevo aprire il pavimento ma ha fatto
passare i cavi in alto con labyrinthus
barano questo è quello che c'è a
bibbiena l'elea 9003 a una dimensione
che occupa un campo da tennis consuma 20
kilowatt roba impensabile con i computer
che abbiamo in tasca oggi no però non
era non ci sono delle grandi novità se
non a livello di integrazione di
velocità le cose che sono state
introdotte nelle l'air 9300 sono anche
quelle che ci sono oggi qui e quando
rappresentata gronchi qui invece quando
da borgolombardo ci siamo spostati a
pregnana io sto quasi per finire per cui
vi lascio veramente un messaggio che è
questo noi ad ivrea per raccontare
questa storia abbiamo fatto un
lavoratore
che si chiama tecnologicamente vi
consiglio di andare sul sito e vedere se
vi interessa dove partiamo dalle
macchine per scrivere prima
dell'olivetti e arriviamo le 9300 e
laboratori didattici per fare in modo di
trasmettere quello che è stata
l'esperienza olivettiana ai giovani di
oggi
questo adriano olivetti in via jervis
l'uomo è illuminato che ha fatto di
tutto su tantissimi campi era un
architetto perché ha fatto il progetto
della val d'aosta
ho finito sto andando fuori vi ringrazio
scusate ma questo discorso richiederebbe
veramente molto tempo
spero di averli stimolato ad andare a
cercare di più e di meglio di quello che
ho potuto dirvi oggi grazie